hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember the movie Toy Story about a
little spaceman doll who thought he was
a real spaceman well what if that toy
was violent psychotic devoid of fun and
would stop at nothing until everything
he deemed a threat was massacred and/or
totally destroyed
it'd be awesome but instead we get small
soldiers
chill Dante director such hits as
gremlins and actually nothing else
financially successful well that's
depressing returns two little creatures
causing a riot throughout the town
except this time is with toys this was
also one of the earliest film from the
newcomer studio DreamWorks and seeing
how they have the habit of Uggla fiying
recent Disney hits it only made sense to
give Toy Story a shot but by no means
god-awful it does make you wonder how
it's still creative idea from a creative
director could get lost in a relatively
forgettable script I mean I remember the
Burger King add more than I remember the
movie was based on that rodeo burger it
was pretty tasty huh you can't handle
the rodeo burger BTW dimensions so let's
watch the film that could live up to its
fat food product this is small soldiers
if you want an idea of how unfocused
this movie is just take a look at how
confused even the logo appears to be
what are we supposed to look threatening
or something no we know we opened up
with a business called Colombo tech we
spent most of its time making the same
commentary Robocop made except for the
Happy Meal demographic introducing
Advance battlefield technology into
consumer products for the whole family
so a military weapon maker acted by
Denis Leary is playing entrepreneur
owning a variety of companies which of
course naturally includes a toy making
industry well don't look so shocked I
remember when down Trump tried to take
over Mattel pull the string she talks
but toy creators played by David Cross
and Jay Mohr aren't meeting the new
presidents big plans they really do that
do what the thing where he punches his
way out of the Bob know know what I'm
sick of I'm sick of commercials that
show us 4x4 trucks popping up to the top
of Mount Rushmore and parking on top of
a brahim Lincoln's head okay I'm sick of
shampoo commercials okay is this just a
way we can combine all this Denis Leary
rants into one so we can save on time
second commercials that shows 4x4 trucks
popping up to the top of Mount Rushmore
you just say like read about people
guys like you wanna keep checking your
answer I want to scrub Cuban cigar the
size of Cincinnati in a non-smoking
section I want to run for the stretch
naked with green jello all of my body
called hey Paul Paul okrs you spot that
stupid British band name called Pulp
Fiction
oh and Tarantino what's with that
goddamn it by the way great we could
just put him under actors who's been
replaced by gimmick so we don't have to
pay them anymore pile
look he's fighting for Seth MacFarlane
you think it's bad so the president
wants the toys to be alive active and
violent which I imagine would be doable
for a guy who's dressed like spikes
behold mr. Mars expects the product to
be ready for shipment in three months
that's right
you only have three months to create
life come on it only took two days to
make Giga pets and even faster to wish
they were dead
come on we all killed ours at some point
these are your security guards and these
are your individual secret passwords
please take a moment to memorize them
now hides gizmo minds in joke so is the
credits roll we can't help but
automatically look over our Joe Dante
checklist rustic old town that looks
like the 50s check whimsical Jerry
Goldsmith's score check dick Miller as a
blue collar worker still unable to
squint his eyes open
check don't worry kids there's plenty
more on the way
and speaking of which he comes across
our normal good-looking boy who for some
reason will still be an outcast a high
school boy named Alice Allen he's
excited because he sees the new action
toys but knows his father who owns a toy
shop won't want to sell anything violent
you know just sort of lend it to me you
got plenty in the truck I'll pay you
back after I tell him and this place
will have made a little money for once
one whole set I'll lose the paperwork
someplace there's better I come back
home fight Manny yes
it won't nice doing business with you a
12 year old boy I just got a drop by
little Susie's raggedy and drug ring
that shit sells fast fortunately
somebody already has interest in the
toys Timmy and his older sister Christie
played by an older than interview with
the vampire but not old enough to be
considered hot yet Kristen Dunst here
made your trip hazard he's the one how
much are these a lot there's no way mom
and dad are gonna buy you one of these
yes they will
didn't you hear it's a lot dollars look
I'll find it and hold it till tomorrow
he promises to hold onto it for her and
then goes home to his room surrounded in
wait let me look at the checklist old
sci-fi nostalgia you can make a bingo
game out of this guy
oh my god you left the vibrator on look
I know it's pg-13 but younger kids might
be watching oh it's just a toy unless
they're designed like no greetings I am
archer emissary of the gorgonites by the
way there's Franklin Gila is the leader
of the gorgonites because you know the
last time he played an action figure
worked out so well in his favor what is
your name I'm Allen no shut up
greetings Allen now shut up what do you
say I'm saying that when the gorgonites
do it it's not illegal his enemy is
Chief hazard played by Tommy Lee Jones
getting his team riled up by lighting
their glowing crutches of power
permission destroyed the gorgonite enemy
defeat him yes sir there will be no
mercy
the real funny thing is that in these
well I guess I have to say a Toy Story
the gorgonites are designed to be the
bad guys and the commandos designed to
be the heroes but listen to how these
things talk if Gordon is not in that
window is it in this one oh yeah Archer
we was hiding even if you can't see
something it doesn't mean it isn't there
sounds like a fucking killer to me and I
get the idea don't judge a book by it's
cover appearances are deceiving heck
even the toy maker said he want the
gorgonites to be the good guys but the
point stands they changed it so that the
aliens would be the villains so from a
marketing standpoint would you ever
guess that this soft-spoken kind I
fluffy eared puppy dog was ever supposed
to be the bad guy sometimes appearance
has got to make a little bit more sense
greetings friends
and lovely double boner here today
oh my twittering birds of evil are no
match for your machine gun piece
yeah whatever blow off or something we
have stereo box but the next morning the
toys had escaped and completely trashed
the place I am in so much trouble
yeah I knew I should have fed them after
midnight but thankfully Christie comes
by to pick up the toys and sees Alan's
predicament
are you pulling some kind of insurance
scam I heard your parents had to move
here because you got kicked out of 10
different schools I did not it was to
only to
so the music's indicating we should have
a moment you need some help they cleaned
up the place but have the annoying
parents from Transformers comes in to be
well half the annoying parents from
Transformers and how do you explain this
I I was dusting it and fell over oh you
were dusting with what a croquet mallet
do I have to have your mom make a
masturbation joke don't force me to have
your mom make a masturbation joke to
make things worse Alan also finds out
that Christy has a boyfriend Christy
what happened I thought you were coming
by practice today sorry Brad something
else too much hi I'm good-looking you I
only have three lines in the whole movie
but you can just assume I'm a douche
come on you can cheer me on
don't worry Alan if there's anything
these movies teach us it's that pity
dating always wins prepare to fire the
muscle well we may as well start this up
the scenes clearly ripping off Toy Story
we already got the toys who thought they
were real now how about the dog chasing
the toy trying to hold on to something
moving on the road and to top it all off
it's a small world after all no I don't
think they technically said that Toy
Story but it's Disney I'm sure they
snuck it in somewhere meanwhile Globo
Tech is busy pushing their new line
SPECT of the 100 merchandise licensees
for the next two phases these for the
next two months you will be on thank God
the rodeo burger ad didn't have that in
it
Burger King we're fuckin scary these
micro processing chips what do they do
and where'd you get them from they were
designed for the Department of Defense
they figure out the chips that they put
in those toys were actually munitions
chips which belong to a division of
course headed by Joe Dante checkoff
number six Robert Picardo worked out
better than you dreamed didn't they
actually there was a little bit of a
problem then it's with your software
yeah I I don't think there's a problem
with the software Ralph
oh you don't he's always so good at
saving a mundane product you can just
start every performance with please date
the cinematic emergency imagine a
microchip imagine it can be used to
instantly upgrade any system then
imagine it can learn what are you
talking about artificial intelligence
you actual intelligence from an
artificial life short way but the
commandos have a plan to capture Archer
and Alan's hull and this of course
brings us to Joe Dante checkoff number
everything in the kitchen being a big
scary weapon to render Gorgon light
alloy you just met your match oh yeah I
mean I understand defending yourself but
he had a tiny kitchen drill and a match
did he really deserve such a harsh
punishment back off creep or I'll get
you with my mini handcuffs my mini
handcuffs
Alan what the hell is going on here I'm
so angry I'm ready not to believe you no
matter what you say it's these toys that
it's like they're alive look come on
Archer back me up here
say something
talk to me Alan Alan please I need to
ask you this are you on crank nah see
what your mother does when you like it
wasn't a masturbation jump but it was
pretty close so yeah if you're wondering
why the toy didn't talk earlier get a
load of this why didn't you say anything
shut up don't talk to me not a word
wise guy uh okay well why not what did
he say something when the kid told him
to say something I must adhere to the
lazy writing that conquered all nineties
children's Phil's
oh you knew I'd be annoying comedic sigh
- god damn it
giggles what a dump celiac okay hey it's
Steve Buscemi if you mix math with red
ball hey it's the organizers oh by the
way yes you made gremlins
please stop reinforcing the idea that
this movie is just gremlins if they were
toys I mean are we gonna have a scene
where the goofy characters do goofy
things that don't in any way evolve the
plot but they're gonna show it anyway
cuz the kids always seem to like it why
do you cut - yeah you know what's coming
look so real go oh yeah I'm sure this
one was already checked off as you knew
it was gonna be in the movie even before
it started while we're at it how long
toys watching ironic TV there's nothing
in windows there's stuff outside them
what stuff you know outside trees Kristi
says happy yogurt the mall and beyond
that that's the highway and beyond that
about a million acres of farm and what's
beyond what are you working your way to
a song the commandos figure out that
Alan is attracted to Christie so they
manage to work their way into her home
and plan on kidnapping her they begin
with her brother
typical sibling response before she
makes it upstairs the commandos decide
to recruit her very bizarre Barbie
collection including Spartan Barbie
yodeling Barbie and fifty shades of grey
Barbie request a three-day pass sir did
i okay not that the existence of these
Barbies isn't awesomely awesome but
there are some pretty strange and
specific outfits in here especially that
one I mean why would anyone have such
strange and peculiar don't work sure I'm
reading too deep into it I mean I'm sure
this isn't anyone's weird perverted
fantasy
Fenne Tish mu fee uh hell Joe Dante we
have to add sexually confused arousal
therapy to the list is a pretty fucked
up I mean okay I can understand ripping
them apart and putting the chips in I
get it it's what you guys do to control
the toys and everything but why the hell
Arthur clothes put back on no really I
want a reason for that why not hell
aren't there clothes put back on there's
no reason for these things to be walking
around practically naked with nothing on
in fact it actually would have looked
funnier there all these strange looking
deformed Barbies and these weird outfits
as well but instead
it just comes across as uncomfortably
creepy I'm sorry I need a minute I got a
research what the hell is wrong with
this guy we'll be back in a moment
you
Wow apparently there is an exact term
for it apparently it's called
justification experimentation serving
unusual sexuality or an abbreviated
terms jazz us Christy gets tangled up in
this kinky in sandy so the boyfriend
tries to come in to saver you work out
what's your sign big boy is it funny
that even though they had a Spartan
soldier an Egyptian queen and an
astronaut they still all talk like dumb
valley girls from the 50s so five
minutes ago are you dumping me like oh
my god this is totally Sparta yo magic
an officer and a gentleman does not
strike a lady yes you just open up their
breast strip them naked and for them to
be your mindless sex videos seriously
Jesus are you scared
we're all scared you'd have to be icing
on a scare
okay what the hell kind of movie did
this become I mean I thought this was
like oh noes not the toys oh they're so
cute nah no this is serious fucking shit
as fuck was nobody getting creeped out
while they were filming this didn't
nobody ever questioned how fucking
bizarre the scene was excuse me
assistant director yes 16 year old
Kirsten Dunst I just want to clarify in
this family film about toys coming to
life
uh-huh I'm to be tied up a sock stuffed
in my mouth taunted in the dark and
covered by naked evil deformed Barbies
uh-huh is that common in kids films
nowadays look just do this the director
says before his other eye starts
twitching
okay ready to start rolling mr. Dante
really they send a ransom video to Allen
and threatened to kill her off if they
don't hand over the gorgonites both
Allen has a plan to in keeping with the
theme of the movie ripoff
Toy Story to get inside to plagiarize
unbe ond y alright what's okay I'm just
prepping for the Shan Lambie movies or
gets a feeling I'm gonna be on this
particular bad boy and now you must be
punished fat you know anything why the
hell do you collect them can you rescue
me anytime
didn't you have a boyfriend yeah but you
ran away after being set on fire what a
wimp
okay you're kidnapped then you're saving
you're afraid then you're left you have
a girly room with a peace poster but a
solid black Led Zeppelin poster right
next to it can you just pick an identity
like Alan who got kicked out to schools
and yet does absolutely nothing that
would cause trouble killing him so they
have a great big chase they finally
outsmart them and the commandos blow up
in a fiery explosion finally bringing
this plastic mess to a close they're
toast and that was small soldiers and
let me tell you it's got some big
problems well it was bad I do it to give
it credit that it was at least a short
loop wait why aren't the clips I
obviously stole from the trailer playing
wait a minute the chip character somehow
still survived and he's building another
army how much longer is this movie 30
minutes we have 30 minutes left to go
what else do you have to do show Frodo
going to the Grey Havens know how
parently the kids have to explain to
their parents how of course the toys
were alive one of those parents play by
Phil Harmon don't worry honey we'll get
you the best deprogram a money can buy
you may remember me from such family pit
parts as Kiki's Delivery Service
pee-wee's Playhouse and the eternal
classic jingle all the way he says that
toy is alive just because it can move a
little what's next the Blue Fairy drops
by with a talking cricket oh great now
they're stealing from AI they finally
see that the dolls are alive and even
get a visit from the toy makers but
shift gets a whole truckload of other
soldiers and apparently not even one of
them being another chip doll because you
know that be funny and they attack the
house
you know it's funny for all the action
drama and suspense that's supposed to be
going on here all I can think about is
how much I really want a rodeo burger I
mean it was amazing it was onion rings
it was barbecue sauce it was cheese I
heard they put it back on the menu
seriously check it out it was playing
broiled on delicious chips you're not
shielded against an electromagnetic
pulse a nuclear blast would wipe them
out they figure out an idea about
jamming the electric transformer
magnetic science teeth fuck and decide
to put into motion and if you had any
doubt that this movie was tired and has
no new ideas whatsoever listen to these
lines literally every single one of them
is a cliche it's kind of amazing you're
not going out there you're not going in
there there's no time it's too dangerous
it's too dangerous
there's no other way there is no other
way you have to trust me you have to
trust him wait we have some more lives
to cut and paste are you mad it looks
like this is it but random Denis Leary
rant hey ours just popped that stupid
British band named pulp so Archer goes
into the danger zone you were all
waiting for it I caved in and gives Alan
time to activate this sciency thing
you stupid toy that's your badass
finishing line huh you stupid toy there
was no other Scorchers you could have
thought up at that moment I don't like
you orchid you stupid or so Alan's about
to get axed but Christy comes in to save
the day yeah well two kisses would throw
me off to the next morning Leary comes
in to patch things up and the gorgonites
managed to get away without anybody
noticing and you sure you guys want to
do this yes Alan you know you might not
find Gorgan it may not even even if you
can't see something it doesn't mean it
isn't there we must sail to toy Valhalla
where we will hunt the mighty squirrel
along the banks of the great creek
and what's the finishing line this movie
goes out in I don't know we stolen from
every other popular movie in existence
let's just steal from Titanic I hope we
don't hit an iceberg high note you went
out on a high note or wasn't incredibly
dated a lame note either way it's not
very good it's not the worst or anything
it just seems like it's a little
confused does it want to be a kid's film
with an edge or an adult film with a
childlike innocence we don't know when I
don't think the film does II nothing
really stands out about it because it's
clear what it's trying to be why Toy
Story gremlins every other status quo
kids film at the time and because of
this it's just kind of boring and
standard except for a few joy scenes
Jesus bottom life is probably not best
to take something marketed as innocent
and cute and make it torturous and scary
and you can bet there's nobody that's
gonna put me through a similar
experience like this ever again island
establish a credit Guy remember it so
you don't have nothing like resting
after a review that clearly over with no
ironic twist concerning the comments
that I made at the barrier
nothing like it at all
this bad boy